jean louis daumas cascadeur michelin
propose annexes wayne easter 600 kg
il ya plein
daphné que monsieur rigolo
mais voilà
je vous salue alors
les agnettes soyez mistral mot dans ce
match est plus malheureuse de ce dernier
vaut vraiment les 1.45 kg
mais au milieu
john morris pas de reproche aux plus
âgés ne soyez ni stars internationales
we begin 5
m
je
et
mister moonlight gentlemen we can
de brighi ou jamais ig bau jours
mesdames et messieurs je vous salue je
vous remercie pour la participation à la
session plénière consacrée à un sujet
deux portes unités coopération militaire
en tant qu outil de contre-mesures à des
défis régionaux en amérique latine et
msr d'ouest
il est à noter que le rôle que dans
l'amérique latine on voit renforcer le
rôle des institutions régionales
financière cette croissance à ses
justifications la région unis 33 pays
avec la population totale supérieure à
six ans à 30 millions d'habitants
la région dispose des réserves
importantes de pétrole au niveau devant
4 pouces 1 25% des frais du monde 30%
des mythos bref on trouve en potentiel
énorme pour le développement financier
social et économique
en même temps des particularités qui
artisans les situations sont pas si
brillant les situations en stable de la
politique antérieure de plusieurs pays
la forte dépendance des gouvernements
des pays de l'amérique latine 1 par
rapport au washington et aux structures
financières qui sont contrôlés par les
états unis
une concurrence féroce pour l'accès à
des ressources naturelles
du continent les différends territoriaux
la présence des groupements armés
illégaux
la dégradation de la situation de crise
les jeunes pensent qu'en pays
la cndhl trafic de drogue le trafic des
armes et la pauvreté aussi importante
évidemment on trouve des liens dits des
causes et et des résultats en problème
local devient globale assez rapidement
alors le problème de la lutter contre le
trafic des stupéfiants c'est un problème
régional c'est un problème au niveau
mondial alors il est tout à fait logique
de se poser les questions comment parer
les menaces et les défis régionaux
qu'une témoignant en amérique latine
quels moyens peuvent être déployées
c'est pour discuter ce sujet q nous
sommes réunis dans cette salle pour
notre session plénière
des vecteurs principaux de notre
discussion sur autres défis et des
menaces à la sécurité de la région à
confluence des acteurs excellent jus non
le rôle des forces armées a dans la
kozah d'assurer la stabilité dans les
régions non la session plénière vont
tenter réunir notre aîné liste c'est
avec un grand bonheur que je vous
présente nos pénaliste et demande un
obus lieu à quillan ministre de la
défense nationale 2a de l'état la
multinationale de bolivie général en
chef la dinepa trine lopes miss de la
défense nationale de la république et
bolivarienne du venezuela interviendra
en vidéo dans la salle nous avons le
vice ministre de la défense chargé de
planification du développement des
forces armées à qui il pourrait répondre
aux allocutions des commentaires
concernant la le vidéo enregistrée par
l'une par monsieur le ministre
troisième panélistes cd audio césaire
avait laissé castilho qui interviendra
n'a par le biais d'enregistrements vidéo
quatrième panélistes rhuys et pesci la
vice ministre de la défense de la
république de pingouins qui interviendra
en téléconférence h et pour conclure le
travail de notre session plénière on
écoutera l'intervention de santiago trsb
dit s10e directeur de centre des études
de la politique et international à
coucou bas je remercie tous les
panélistes pour leur disponibilité
hier à l'heure de
la discussion de la lutte informationnel
on a parlé de cette déficience de
l'information fiable digne du premier
main qui serait digne de confiance
aujourd'hui nous avons cette opportunité
inui d'écouter directement les
interventions à des gens qui sont les
mieux placés pour nous faire part de la
situation actuelle dans leur état dans
le région pour recommencer le travail
d'autres sessions plénières je passe
métro le micro à edmond des vidéos avec
l arménie sonne la défense de l état
multinational de la bolivie
c'était une personnalité qui ait de
nombreuses qui a beaucoup d'expérience
dans domaine politique administrative et
qui occupe maintenant le poste du
ministre de la défense de plusieurs mois
bonjour mesdames et messieurs je salue
tous les représentants des pays
étrangers tous les participants de notre
conférence d'aujourd'hui
je remercie le gouvernement russe et en
personne a le président russe vladimir
poutine
je nous allons discuter aujourd'hui les
questions de la coopération militaire
les antes à faire face aux menaces à la
sécurité internationale dans les régions
de l'amérique latine
je vais
faire mon intervention en deux parties
pour que ce soit plus commode à suivre
alors aujourd'hui nous allons discuter
et les opportunités de la coopération
militaire dans les régions de l'amérique
latine
pour ceux d'entre nous qui est chargé
d'assurer la défense la coopération
internationale nous connaissons assez
bien la situation dans cette région ce
qui n'est pas le cas pour le large
public
étant donné des changements c'est rapide
de la situation dans différentes petter
de notre combat contre le sort de crimes
et délits étaient organisées dans
l'article de 144 de la constitution de
la république et d'olivier nord qui
stipule que les forces armées doivent
garder l'indépendance et la stabilité de
l'état assuré la priorité de la
constitution et participer au
développement l'ensemble du pays
aujourd'hui nous parlerons de cette
coopération dans la région de l'amiante
latina à tous les acteurs la coopération
c'est un outil traditionnels et qui vise
à consolider l'indépendance face à
l'affluence de l'amérique heures du nord
et de l'europe à la bolivie c'est une
république et qui a une longue route à
l'indépendance de poc de formel lot
d'indépendance été signé après le combat
de unis et d'éclairer la perte la
défaite de l'empiré espagnol
ensuite en 1810
les républiques de l'amérique du sud
on a certes et je resterai des
frontières kan avait à l'époque même ni
encore et ans y est que pour renforcer
son indépendance notre territoire et de
plus de deux millions de mètres carrés
c'est qu'ils n'auront ans parmi les plus
grands pays de l'avenir du sud étant
libéré s'étant libéré du colonialisme
étrangers mais l'avarice des
corporations à trangé lié avec une
mauvaise politique et à tes dirigeants à
un bolivien nous a fait perdre presque
la moitié de notre territoire
actuellement on n'a que ennuyons km²
nous avons perdu sortie à la mer et nos
pipoles seulement le 5e place à parmi
les états de la région en fonction de
notre superficie mais les menace à 102,6
persistantes après la victoire d'evo
morales le premier président à l'automne
deux ans avant le chef du département
d'état des états unis a déclaré que
normalement les gouvernements ne suscite
pas c'est le premier la première fois
que l amérique en amérique latine en et
a pu changer la donne
et là on a fait sa pub olivier a connu
des surcoûts considérables liés au
démontage devant sept missiles sol air
eau qui est destiné à la défense
anti-aérienne de notre pays
ensuite les etats-unis ont envoyé qu'en
tant qu'ambassadeur philip goldberg qui
a occupé le poste de chef de département
chargé de la guerre en bosnie à partir
de 2004 jusqu'à 2006 il était chef de
l'émission à frichti nabucco chevaux
alors ce qu'il a su faire séparer cette
région de la serbie l'anem cette année
même à bolivie sont arrivées elles et
mercenaires yougoslave sous le
commandement d'un ressortissant bolivien
leur objectif cp l'assassinât du
président morales qui devrait lancer la
guerre civile mais à l'exil de
l'ambassadeur robert et la liquidation
de ces formations à l'essai terme et ont
su à en redire à cette guerre civile et
qui serait a soutenu par l'armée et les
gardes santa cruz et la partie
conservatrice de l'élite nationale
ces élites ont repris la tentative de
coup d'état en 2018 en prétextant par la
fraude électorale qui n'a pas été
prouvée ils ont formé en est
et à deux dictatures qui a ignoré
pendant onze heures d'un mois jusqu'aux
élections au 2 décembre 2020 lorsque le
peuple de le peuple bolivien s'est
proclamé a pour l'heure pour l'écologie
socialiste on a su après que le ministre
de défense a essayé d'interdire
l'inauguration de notre président actuel
en organisant en coup d'état
c'est comme ça que le conservateur on
vous désirez des sommes fait rêver des
richesses de bolivie la lutte pour la
souveraineté nationale contre les
puissances étrangères dont je viens de
parler est la même elle est à peu près
avec quelques différences a été connue
par tous les pays du continent tout me
répéte ont été occupées par les
britanniques et saufs bolivie et le
paraguay à ces pays qui ont des côtes
maritimes ceux qui facilitent
l'intrusion et l'intervention en ce qui
concerne les états unis thomas jefferson
croyez l'indépendance et ses positions
ont rompu leur or reflet dans les
constitutions régional a adopté en du
cycle jefferson voulait éviter que les
colonies soit sous tutelle heures de la
grande bretagne au lieu de risquer
les vassaux de des états unis ensuite
james moore a rédigé sa doctrine qui est
respectée jusqu'à nos jours
l'amérique pour les américains c'est que
sans désir des refus de l'intervention
américaine au sol sud africain
ce concept est devenu plus proche pour
citoyen la mairie qui pour les amériques
ans de même que l'amérique du sud pour
les sud-américains
c'est mon c'est mon boulevard a prévenu
des dangers de dante et réalisme
américain en témoignant l'effort
d'unifier les république nouvellement
née sur le continent
vachon a vu son ombre une minasse dans
cette intégration qui pourrait porter en
dommages pauli à la politique d'invasion
américaine
le bolivar et mais sans avoir vu son
rêve se réaliser son rêve sur l'union de
l'amérique latine un autre sur les
cendres de l'amérique latine connaissait
très bien les dom à des dangers de
l'impérialisme américain et dans sa
lettre à vent juste la veille de sa mort
à dans le combat il a dit que chaque
jour ils subissent et une menace
mortelle à mais il était prêt pour
mourir
un beau sapin pour sa patrie pour
protéger le coup bas contre l' influence
américaine et il était disposé à
poursuivre son activité mais kouba n'a
pas su accéder à l'indépendance à
l'époque en 1901 vers public a dû rester
soumis en dépendantes avec la médiation
des états unis qui ont érigé un
amendement à la première constitution
cubaine et les autoriser a enchéri dans
les affaires de la ville par une
intervention le jour le décide le panama
le grenade et d'autres pays ont souffert
de leur gérance et direct à des états
unis le 1er juin de 1959 lorsque fidel
castro et ernesto che guevara ont donné
la lan dépendance au cuba et les etats
unis ont décrite et le blocus économique
ce qui a coûté 400 milliards de dollars
à l'économie continue la perte des
exportations la hausse du prix pour les
produits importés et à toute sorte de
dommage au développement de la société
civile à l'amérique latine a connu des
manoeuvres des manipulations usante en
ternir l'union deux des pays de l'est
non même durant le vent premiers siècles
les tendances impériale des états unis
nous prend la forme des coups d'état
d'où comme c'était le cas de brésil ou
d'argentine ou ou des coups d'état dans
les tentatives ont eu lieu au venezuela
alors la sécurité et la défense ont une
importance clé pour les pays de la
région visant à assurer
alors on dépendance en utilisant leurs
ressources naturelles pour leur public
bolivien de sécurité c'est une bonne
heure dix au niveau de vie sains
abordable la sécurité alimentaire 1 sur
need et de la santé publique et je lui
volet éducatif les sources dans le cloud
à et de sécurité sociale de mes façons
on peut hein signalé l'importance de la
coopération militaire avec la russie
c'est un vrai plaisir
de visiter votre grand pays dont le
peuple a autant contribuer développement
de l'humanité
les relations entre nos états ont été
instaurées 1980 en 1945
olivier a eu des relations diplomatiques
avec l'union soviétique mentionné qu en
2009 que nos relations ont connu un des
landes portant lorsque eva morales n'a
devenu président de du pays et la russie
a signé avec nous henri convention cadre
sur la coopération assuré coopération en
militaire aujourd'hui en 2000 ventes et
en sultan de renfoncer notre coopération
d'un domaine de la défense civile
à l'invitation des conséquences des
graves sauf naturelle situations
d'urgence les changes d'expérience afin
de réaliser des programmes et des
projets visant à prévenir ou à du cir
les circonstances des situations
d'urgence et de catastrophe naturelle
pour lutter contre les trafics de toutes
sortes polisy déclarera sa disponibilité
à renforcer le potentiel de ces forums
et anchamps achetant de nouveaux
matériels de guerre
fabriqué en russie ce qui me permettra
de participer à des opérations
humanitaires
interdire les vols et les cours au
dessus de notre territoire national
bolivie a profité de l'expérience russe
dans le domaine de la construction des
missiles par la coopération au niveau de
la formation des ingénieurs militaires
pour ne jamais revivre la situation de
2005 lorsqu'un état est rangé ses permis
le droit de débrancher est désactivé
notre défense antiaérienne aller notre
peuple aspire à un renforcement de notre
coopération nous aspirons à la paix sans
easy money 1 mondial ou le call ou la
confiance règne au lieu de la peur je le
remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre de
notre estimation de la situation
politique intérieure de la bolivie
évidemment les des clés que j'ai entendu
c'est la protection de l'indépendance
des états en reformulant notre écrivain
classique très connu qui parlait de la
révolution que la dépendance ou vont
quelque chose quand on sait se protéger
par des moyens modernes y compris ceux
politiques informatiques économique
merci encore une fois et d'après
l'agenda
maintenant nous allons écouter par
visioconférence le général en chef
messieurs padrines à lopez qui avait
servi et en occupant différents postes
de commandement depuis deux maîtresses
et ali dirigeait le commandement
stratégique qui devenu le position clé
pour qu'il soit nommé au poste du
ministre de la défense
maintenant je propose d'écouter
l'allocution du ministre de la défense
sur le sujet de la sécurité régionale
au nom de simón bolívar le aug chavez au
nom de nicolás maduro le conacoh tunnel
de la république et du venezuela
j'aimerais transmettre ses salutations
chaleureuses arménie au président de la
fédération de russie vladimir poutine
ministre de défense c'est sergueï
choïgou offrait réhausseur de ce grand
pays et à tous les participants à cette
9e conférence de moscou sur la sécurité
internationale
je suis reconnaissant de cette
possibilité unique est de toucher le
sujet de la sécurité régionale nous
connaissons que l'humanité actuellement
on fait face avec une situation
historique extrêmement dur et où les
problèmes de caractère économique social
ethnique et religieux se sont aggravées
pendant le dernier décès mia en
provoquant une des perturbations
collective de massey qui se manifeste
par des ambiguïtés par rapport au statu
quo existant pendant plusieurs centaines
d'années dirigé par une élite et riche
qui aspirent à générer plus de bénéfices
en même temps nous voyons des
changements technologiques est de très
grande vitesse qui se manifeste d'un
jour à l'autre des innovations dans le
domaine d'europe ou totti cnit
nanotechnologies intelligence
artificielle creed aux devises économie
numérique et et réseaux sociaux qui
représentent 1 vraiment un tsunami
d'informations une ambiguïté par rapport
à fait comment chacune de ces
innovations va influencer sur les
aspects de la vie et surtout en
comprenant que finalement la place de
l'être humain peut disparaître danse
et écosystèmes par rapport à ce qui a
été déjà exposé à l'année précédente
2001 et a été marqué par le foehn et
médiatrice de lakovic 19 qui a généré la
ponte démunis vers celle qui a fait
revenir les dialogues type tiers entre
le socialisme et le capitalisme et ça
pourrait être bizarre mais ce prénom
mais parfois ce vérin les gouvernements
se verront de certains pays attachait
plus d'importance à à la valeur de leur
marché par ap ir indicateur de leur
bourse par rapport à leur propre vie en
démontrant leur fragilité et
vulnérabilité de leur système de la
santé publique est toujours dans ces
situations les états unis ne domine dans
situation septième puissance qui avait
toujours essayé de jouer un rôle d j'ai
mon universel et parce que l'air elle
est et n'est pas soumise aux standards
de cette aiguë du pouvoir exercer car à
l'aspiration vers ces politiques et
politiques et surtout pour atteindre ces
objectifs géostratégiques stratégique a
acquis un caractère multi facettes non
traditionnels que nous avons appelé un
modèle un but de la guerre qui sert de
naughty de la corporatocratie globale
qui a pour intention de ne faire venir
vers un modèle obsolète du monde
unipolaire ou
surtout un amérique centrale et
l'amérique du sud comme dans la région
de la mer des caraïbes
plusieurs conflits surtout sous
différentes formes se démontre dans sa
majorité dans l'impérialisme classique
des états unis on est là dessus on ne
peut se rappeler des attaques et des
interventions militaires malheureusement
connu et surtout des bases militaires
navales placés dans différentes régions
du monde
elle se fait te reposer non seulement
une violation des principes de la
souveraineté de l'autodétermination mais
aussi bien projette des nouveaux
principes et d'interviews
d'internationalisme qui se sont
matérialisées sous forme de coup d'état
similaires ce qui a été lésé contre hugo
chavez en 2002 manuel zelaya au honduras
en 2009 hernando logo opara guerre 2012
dilma rousseff au brésil 2 mai 16 et evo
morales en bolivie en 2019 et tout cela
était organisé dans le cadre de la
doctrine ou offert kit utilisé depuis
longtemps sur le continent et qui a pour
but d'imposer s'est approché surtout
s'approprier de ses ressources
naturelles énormes dont ces pays
possèdent pas ce que par rapport mini
jupe et là on peut toujours affirmé
qu'il avait été toujours vraiment une
cible prioritaire pour l'empiré
américain
surtout en 2019 au togo raphaël chavez a
été élu oppose du président nous avons
vu le développement multilatéral de
cette guerre non traditionnels et multi
facettes dont la tension s'est aggravée
après la mort du leader en 2013
et surtout cette campagne s'est
poursuivie avec le changement de régime
en combinant des forces sévère et
flexible après le 8 mars 2015 quand
l'administration de messieurs obama a
signé le décret en voyant notre pays et
en définissant notre pays en tant que
menace inhabituelle et extraordinaire
pour les états unis et ce décret a grevé
le blocus économique et financier les
sanctions et aussi le volet d avoir
aussi bien que l'intention des
etats-unis pour imposer le double
pouvoir par connaissance d'un président
parle elle de la part d'autres états du
monde surtout c'était a provoqué des
protestations manifestation avec
violence et aussi des attaques contre
les objets à destination spéciale et a
proposé de financer les personnels pour
faire les attaques contre les dirigeants
du pays est assurée l'intervention sur
le territoire du pays
il est visé aussi assurée ce qu'on
appelle le phénomène des balkans dans
cette région où des bandes armées
illégales colombienne fonctionne et qui
pratique et j'ai trafic des stupéfiants
le commerce des êtres humains et qu'ils
étaient protégés de la part de certains
agents américains et surtout qui
profitent de l'état de la colombie qui
néglige par le res pouvoir desserrer lui
surtout dans les régions
transfrontalières passé qu il s'appuie
sur la structure de la nouvelle et
grenade qui a pour intention d'exporter
son activité mais il était vers d'autres
pays et il est à noter que ces derniers
mois ces groupements sont devenus les
raisons de la mort de nos militaires et
hop pour atteindre ses buts
il utilise les procédés de meurtre
surtout la violence armée
c'est une activité criminelle et
transfrontalière de ce groupe représente
une menace d'ensemble pour cette région
qui nécessitent et doit être vraiment
étudié attentivement de la part de
différents structures eas organismes
internationaux parce qu'on pourrait très
bien que la majorité des stupéfiants des
productions de colombie sont envoyés
vers l'amérique vers l'europe et de la
façon similaire la prolifération et la
propagation et l'élargissement des
activités de ces groupements ont un
impact négatif sur le développement
durable et la qualité de la vie de la
population et dans ce contexte nos prévu
non le monde entier
sur une vraie nécessité de développer
les mécanismes cours qui permettrait
d'arrêter cette forme fille
d'intervention surtout par des proxy qui
un impact négatif sur la souveraineté et
l'intégrité du territoire du venezuela
et ne favorise pas la stabilité dans la
région
merci beaucoup de votre attention ici
dans ces salles nous avons l'adjoint de
la défense l'amiral velasquez bastide au
si vous avez des questions il pourrait
détailler les réponses sur les problèmes
posés à mon tour maintenant j'aimerais
vous remercier monsieur bâti de sa bulle
allocution très intéressante dans votre
comme ministre de la défense qui a
détaillé les problèmes existants et les
solutions éventuelles et surtout pour
pallier aux activités des structures
maintenant nous pouvons continuer notre
discussion maintenant je propose des
côtés et la question vidéo préparée par
le général de cure le commandant en chef
de l'armée de la république du nicaragua
qui surtout qui va parler des des
activités des partisans pendant depuis
dix ans excellence monsieur le ministre
général de l'armée sur y échoue à me
défendre la fédération de russie
j'exprime ma gratitude vers la
connaissance pour l'orientation qui nous
intéressait de prendre notre
anticipation la 9e conférence de moscou
sur la sécurité internationale
work from here est d'importance dans
ledit nyon de nos efforts
les emplois du thé cours assure la
sécurité crs une plate forme importante
des échanges d'expériences de discussion
des tendances actuelles et des eaux
menace surgissantes l'affluence globale
de la pandémie de kobe de 19 n'est pas
sous-estimer c'est une vraie très
vigilent tragédie humaine qui a porté de
morts et de souffrances a arrêté la
circulation normale des marchandises et
des personnes a largement impacté le
développement économique de tous les
pays du monde
nous sommes solidaires avec les
gouvernements et les les formes est de
tous les pays qui ont subi ce tome pas
que négatif de dako vide
je dois vous partagez cul dans l'eure
mais de nicaragua à partir de 2019 après
les premiers cas signalés de
décontamination
nous savons a ordonné de présenter tous
les potentiels et militaires pour
assister à la réalisation des programmes
dans le domaine de la santé publique et
pour et éviter les pertes de plus
précieux que nous avons la vider le
citoyen nous avons pris la décision de
participer à ce feu romain dont
l'importance est encore encore accru vu
le contexte actuel non sont toujours
favorables à la participation à des
conférences paraît étant persuadé gurs
ces discussions sont favorables à la
création d'emplois des points comme en
élaboration d'un concept comment comptez
y ait des cadres légaux légale ad chaque
pays en ce qui concerne la coopération
militaire ça reste
une des questions discutées durant cette
conférence je crois important de porter
votre attention
à une condition considérable c'est la
possibilité de porter sa contribution au
soutien de l'agenda actuelle dans le
domaine de la lutte conte landais pour
la sécurité c'est une vision qui doit
être argumentée par la politique visant
à le construire en demande à
multipolaire nous tous nous pouvons
contribuer à au profit de ces
discussions qui aboutira perd là un
solution valable c'est l'expérience et
qui n'est pas à sous-estimer et le temps
en temps de crise un des principes clés
cadre facilitant l'accès à cette
coopération
ces processus sont basés des capacités
des buses en a qui sont propres forces
armées et son complice et pour le
renforcement de nos efforts à ce kényan
l'application n'iront la conférence
d'aujourd'hui il faut privilégier les
discussions et des informations
qui aa permettrait de dépister les
tendances actuelles qui sont négatifs
pour la sécurité internationale faut
dépister les facteurs de risques et les
menaces qui à court moyen terme peuvent
violer un autre agenda et l'union et
dégrader le niveau de sécurité de nos
pays
j'ai aussi été en simple exemple le
nicaragua en pays avec les populations
de six millions d'habitants qui se
trouvent en ce sens de l'amérique du sud
au centre na li continue nos centres de
entre les amériques nord et du sud
le surface est à peu près cent trente
mille kilomètres carrés la ligne côtière
de 576 km de m caraïbes
nous sommes une nation qui vit en paix
stabilité est calme ayant le plus haut
niveau de sécurité dans les régions de
la mairie centrale du pont de vue
militaire je tiens à souligner que cette
fête
42e anniversaire de sa création nous
sommes parmi les fondateurs de la
conférence des représentants des forces
armées de la mairie centrale
l'effort le forum pour les consacrer aux
questions de coopération de
l'intégration militaire en privilégiant
les consensus et pour la résolution des
différends et les mesures n'a de
renforcement de la confiance
l'intégration militaire au niveau
régional et forcément promu par
l'organisation de cette conférence nous
avons organisé des centres de formation
descendent et des observatoires pour
étudier des questions d'intérêt commun
nous avons créé des unités d humanité
rats pour assister les pays
le cas des situations d'urgence ou
racistes et d'autres unités des forces
armées ont changé dans grupo niveau dans
bataillon des centres riz juno qui
doivent être envoyées aux principaux 2-1
coopération mutuelle dans le domaine des
droits de l'hommme à de manille terre
des opérations de maintien de la paix de
l'est contre la criminalité organisée
la surveillance écologique le déminage
humanitaire
le dernier ce centre est et écriront
nicaragua avec le soutien à leurs âmes
de la fédération de russie
nous avons rédigé en plan complexe de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et la
criminalité organisée nous avons adopté
un programme des changes des
spécialistes mais des terreaux du niveau
de formation pour l'associer à un autre
entraînement de combat la coopération
visant à assurer l'efficacité de cette
étude des épreuves joie de vue est que
le monde a des défis et des menaces
surgissant ces menaces sont bien
organisés et à saper la sécurité globale
qu'on ait ce développement permanent
s'adapte ce qui est
en plus difficile leur éradication le
plus proche cette vérité ce sont les
conséquences du changement climatique et
de la part des deux communes 19 ce sens
les défis réels et qui ont des vulgaires
une robe sculpturale vulnérabilité de
l'humanité et la nécessité accrue de
s'unir pour surmonter ensemble des
situations et faste il faut aussi
mentionner l'usagé permanent et continu
dans différents coins du monde des
stratégies non militaires qui font
naître les événements déstabilisant au
le situation antérieure des paysans
dépendant la déstabilisation qui vise à
provoquer des coups d'état favorisant
les angles père et des acteurs étrangers
il s'agit de 1 le pouvoir de la pouvoir
tous de la force douce sortent pas aguer
intellectuelle révolution de couleur qui
ont pour objectif
la défaite est des institutions légales
à de l'état indépendant
aujourd'hui la pandémie n importe qu du
mal et des dégâts à avec des duran
conséquences économiques pour les sites
orient et pour les organismes nationaux
y compris les forces armées
je tiens à souligner que les questions
concernant la défense des pays de
l'hémisphère ouest a toujours six
médailles il faut lutter contre le
terrorisme le trafic des drogues
la migration clandestine tous ces flux
aux impacts la stabilité la paix et le
développement durable de la région en se
posant en fait à ce que la stratégie de
réaction doit être conforme à notre
agenda à nous dans le domaine de la
sécurité et afin d'assurer plus de
sécurité
nos apportons notre contribution à la
sécurité régionale en se guidant par ces
principes nous déployons nos efforts
afin de structurer les
les postes aux défis et créer les bases
de la coopération internationale visant
à assurer le soutien de notre
coopération avec le respect de droit
international et la sérénité des états
indépendants
il s'agit de faire dépister à étudier
des menacer principal à montbazens des
conditions réelles du monde contemporain
entre sans les limites de la coopération
bilatérale multilatérale le terrorisme
international reste le fléau majeur
ayant le caractère transfrontalier qui
touche toutes les régions en asie en
afrique et au moyen rien et représentent
ces rues to b les fastes et pour
l'europe et certains pays de l'amérique
à la diminution du nombre des grandes
attaques terroristes n'a ne démontre pas
la baisse du niveau de terrorisme
nous savons que ces dernières cinq ans
les la région le plus contaminé par
semaine cette menace
ces résidus sud et de sud est allé pays
ayant le niveau le plus accrues de
l'activité terroriste c'est l'irak la
syrie la libye somalie yémen pakistan
l'inde république démocratique du congo
les philippines public centre l'amérique
est centrale et le buzzer de caraïbes ce
sont les régions avec l'activité moins
prononcée du terrorisme ni korhogo a
comme n'importe quel pays du monde
de niro cible le terrorisme
international personne n'est épargné
alors avec les ensembles avec mais les
pays de notre région et n'aurait les ans
la coordination de nos activités visant
à créer des systèmes de prévention des
attaques terroristes
la coopération à ce vecteur vise à
contrôler les frontières territoriales
les nationaux et les ports et les
aéroports
je profite de cette occasion pour
réaffirmer notre position d'après lequel
nous devons profiter de tous nos moyens
pour renforcer la lutte contre le
terrorisme avec le soutien des nations
unies
nous rejetons toutes sortes d'actions
qui a pourrait encourager ou financer
cette menace terroriste n'aurait
affirmant que toute attaque terroriste
n'a aucune justification étant dirigées
contre à la vie humaine en cours en défi
consiste à l'activité des groupes
criminels organisés transfrontaliers qui
a beau cède au trafic de drogue en non
d'échelle dans toutes les régions du
monde entier à la propagation de cette
menace continue ce qui est signe ce qui
est témoignée par à l'augmentation de la
quantité de laboratoire mais fabrication
des drogues synthétiques
l'augmentation des territoires utilisé
pour la culture de les stupéfiants ce
qui représente une vraie menace pour les
états de la région afin de
lutter contre cette menace il me faut de
la coordination et de la d'action
commune le trafic des stupéfiants dépend
de plusieurs ponts lit avec les
fabrications le le coc la
commercialisation et lusage actuellement
on produit à peu près 3000 tonnes
métriques et par parent des stupéfiants
qui a qui passent à destination de
l'asie de l'europe pour l'année 2000
vent les quantités des personnes
dépendant de la consommation de drogues
et s'élève au niveau supérieur à 36
millions de personnes au nicaragua
réalise une stratégie étatique à
enterrer leurs murs de rétention c'est
en cercle défensif qui y est basée à la
réalisation des activités des
renseignements visant à retenir
canaliser et intercepter les drogues qui
sont emportés dans le pays
en hésitant tout transite par les le cas
l'été pour éviter l'affluence les
phrases du drogué sur la société et de
notre pays
cette stratégie est rendu efficace à
partir de 2020 jusqu'aujourd'hui nous
avons saisi 3800 qui le grand mas des
stupéfiants annuellement le trafic de
cocaïne qui circulent à travers notre
pays s'élèvent au niveau de 600 ou 700
tonnes au nicaragua grâce aux efforts
conjoints en deux
services de sécurité et du ministère de
la défense nous pouvons a signalé qu'il
n'avons pas de cartel n'avons pas des
organisations terroristes sur notre
territoire nous n'avons pas des
organisations criminelles organisées
nous n'avons pas de gang ni des
groupements illicites nous n'avons pas
des pistes de décalage de terry sage
clandestine et ni des laboratoires plans
distincts
nous ne sommes pas en pays à
commercialisant des drogues au nord de
la région de l'afrique centrale
on signalait les cas de violation de
violences lié avec les organismes
intitulé appelé marc les gangs de jeunes
qui généreront au niveau de criminalité
a est en lien avec le trafic de drogue
et à la criminalité organisée
noko d'après des évaluations au renard à
peu près 90 milles à membres de ce
groupement réussite qui contrôle
plusieurs pays dans les régions il vise
contrôler le territoire assurer le
trafic de drogue et des assassinats
ce qui a fait augmenter les taux de
l'assassinât dans la région hakimi nasa
en gros la sécurité régionale au
nicaragua nous n'avons pas de ce gain du
jeune une autre question d'importance à
ces la migration illégale est la
vocation du terrorisme en fragilité de
la population la pauvreté les poursuites
à des causes ethniques religieuses font
la base qui fait surgir qui fait naître
des flux migratoires massifs temps
différent qu'on demande en générant des
crises humanitaires qui touche les bd
transit et les pays de destination de
ces flux des réfugiés
c'est en effet qui représente en danger
important la sécurité internationale
lorsque les flux migratoires
susmentionnés sont utilisées par des
organismes des terroristes à défend de
recrutement de leurs partisans pour les
faire ensuite transportés dans les pays
cibles au nicaragua les flux migratoires
passe a le plus souvent du sud pour en
violente nos frontières pour attendre
leur compte destination finale les états
unis d'amérique dans la période à partir
de 2020 nous avons arrêté plus de 9000 à
200 immigrés les sites illégaux de
différentes nationalités y compris issus
des pays d'activité des organismes
terroristes ou des pays déchirés père de
faure conflit en termes haut débit en
crise humanitaire et je voudrais
proposer plusieurs sujets discutés au à
fléchir pour la lutte globale 1 contre
les menaces contre compromettant la
sécurité internationales on a besoin
d'une participation coordonnée et
cohérente
2 les acteurs en plein respect des de la
législation internationale et locale
l'affluence de cette pandémie
d'envergure mieux connue c'est vrai
tombées considérable en provoquant la
crise des systèmes de la santé publique
en augmentant le niveau de mortalité en
faisant naître le sentiment
d'instabilité dans sûreté parmi elles et
citoyen d'une pays s'est défait aussi
dégradé les caractéristiques économiques
et la situation financière des citoyen
le suivi et le contrôle de cette
question nécessite de nos ministères de
défense organisé ses efforts pour
assister le système national de santé
publique et ce qui a été fait dans notre
pays et je crois qu'elle est au portant
et nécessaire de poursuivre le travail à
ce vecteur pour réfléchir les solutions
qui seraient favorables au développement
et au renforcement des relations entre
les états et entre les ministères de la
défense pour renforcer le niveau de
confiance mutuelle à dynamiser la
coopération afin de trouver les réponses
aux défis et aux menaces actuelles
nous sommes reconnaissants au général
d'armée sergueï choïgou pour
l'invitation à participer dans le dans
ce forum d'importance je veux remercier
chers collègues
oh je veux remercie je n'ai castille des
eaux où son intervention vient chercher
il est à noter que salue les actions
déstabilisant mentionné par le speaker
comme les révolutions de couleur les
actions de la force de ce sort à mérite
une attention particulière à l'ignorance
de ses activités et risque d'avoir des
retombées néfastes sur la sécurité de
l'état et sur la sécurité régionale
maintenant je pensais parole vice
ministre de la défense de la république
de paris est chargée des questions de la
politique à la défense colonel service
médical c'est on le doit à la coville
est peut-être maîtrise dans le domaine
des études et stratégiques de la défense
et spécialistes dans le domaine de la
médecine militaire
je passais par ci lui plaît bonjour
j'aimerais saluer chaleureusement depuis
la république du paraguay le coeur de
l'amérique du sud surtout rapport le
général monsieur trop chine et aussi à
tous les organisateurs et tous les
participants de la part de monsieur
ministre de la défense monsieur s'auto
lazimi rap hawtin et tous les pouvoirs
de la fille les autorités de la
fédération de russie et tout les
participants 17 conférences
internationales dans le domaine de la
sécurité
le sujet dans mon allocution s'appelle
la coopération militaire en tant que
outils d'opposition aux défis et en
menace dans l'amérique latine et dans
l'hémisphère sud ce qui en fait
l'amérique c'est une région où il n'y a
pas de niveau de coopération de
rivalités géopolitiques comme dans
d'autres points du monde
en plus ils ne représentent pas de
risque du point de vue de prolifération
des armes
nbc ici il n'ya pas de conflits
interétatiques conventionnel après les
événements du 11 septembre 2001 nous
avons vu des changements dans la
perception des menaces est de la
sécurité parce que les états unis sont
devenues un objet de l'attaqué directe
sans précédent de la part de réseaux
terroristes et multinationales et leurs
agendas dans le domaine de la sécurité
nationale a été révisée à cause de cette
menace est et dans ce contexte air ils
ont élaboré le la déclaration de
sécurité dans les deux amériques qui
reconnaît une large gamme de menaces en
ligne
divisant et classant en plusieurs
catégories les menaces traditionnelles
ils compris des conflits interétatiques
et de nouvelles menaces
les résultats de la mondialisation aussi
bien que des défis qui s'explique par
des faiblesses économiques et ce ciel de
la région qui n'a pas direct sur la
sécurité
provenant de la pauvreté et de la
faiblesse institutionnelle dépit donc
nous voyons l'apparition de nouveaux
concepts de la sécurité de nouveaux
caractères de l'hémisphère occidental
basé sur les menaces d'actualité
suivante les menaces dues à la sécurité
comme le terrorisme la criminalité
transfrontalière organisée par le trafic
est illégal des stupéfiants la
corruption le blanchiment d'argent au
chip aussi bien que le trafic est l'égal
des armes
en plus il ya des menaces de la part de
la nature et pour la santé publique
comme l'y pandémie épidémie calamités
naturelles et la pollution de
l'environnement
des menaces ont direct comme la
cybercriminalité est aussi bien les
menaces de posséder des armes baisser
par des personnes privées ou des
groupements terroristes qui peuvent agir
dans l'hémisphère mais pour nous les
e-menaces les plus se poser pour les
pays de l'amérique latine que s'agit
tout d'abord des calamités naturelles
surtout dans la région de l'amérique
latine et des du bassin des caraïbes
c'est la criminalité organisée et le
trafic illégal des stupéfiants qui qui
ont un impact de plus grand niveau ils
représentent la menace commune pour tous
les pays qui doivent battre en commun
contre ces menaces dans le cas de la
stratégie de vision commune et
finalement il y provoquant au même plus
le nombre de morts par rapport aux
guerres continue de l'efficacité de ces
menaces dans la région de l'amérique
latine les très important d'avancer au
cours du processus de l'intégration
sous-régionale aussi bien que d'assurer
le développement multilatéral et
internationales dans le domaine de la
sécurité et de la défense qui doit
devenir paradigme qui doit être prise en
compte
et pour rendre ces possibilités est réel
et il faut se former en tant que acteur
intégré ce qui nécessite vraiment la
cohésion interne et des actions basées
sur les accords face aux situations
communes est spécifique mais le progrès
dans le cas de la copie oreilles ce
métier latéral et n'a pas été
significatif et parce qu'il y avait des
accords bilatéraux qui deux minutes et
dans le cadre de ce qui a été exposé la
sécurité la défense
un terme aussi bien que le rôle des
forces armées en amérique latine dans le
bassin des caraïbes des pompes de
l'agitation interne de chacun des pays
et des pousses disposition du conseil de
sécurité nationale qui diffère en
fonction de la région est le paraguay
soulignait une grande nécessité de
réorienter les missions traditionnelles
et de ses forces armées d'élargir le
rôle dans le domaine de la défense de
lassus kir était ce qui leur permettra
d'acquérir une nouvelle capacité de
réaliser les missions qui prévoit pas
forcément l'implication de toutes leurs
capacités possible était classique
en plus il est nécessaire d'avoir et
d'assurer une aspiration vers une
coopération militaire qui représente un
outil important dans la lutte contre
c'est un point faible aussi bien que
dans le développement des possibilités
de reconnaissance contre la criminalité
organisée en inspirant un essayant de
minimiser leur impact sur la société et
de prévenir leur élargissement
et finalement en conclusion j'aimerais
remarquer que l'amérique latine se
trouvait sur un un carrefour est très
fragile ou des décisions crise dans le
domaine de la reconnaissance
or on en a plus on sur le futur de la
sécurité régionale est le renforcement
de leur démocratie à la force et la
caractère primordial de la loi aussi
bien que le succès de position aurait
post à la crim été organisée merci
beaucoup de votre attention
merci beaucoup madame pesci pour votre
allocation est très fort très brillante
pour analyse
très concrète exacte des menaces surtout
dans le cadre la stabilité mais les
terres et il faut surtout utilisé et
prendre en compte de nouvelles approches
à la construction et programmation
militaire continue de toute la gamme des
missions militaires qui touche non
seulement l'utilisation des armes ici
pour couvrir d'autres tâches évidemment
nous voudrions souhaité des succès dans
la mise en place et la réalisation du
nouveau concept visant à assurer la
sécurité et mettant j'aimerais vous
présenter et passer la parole à madame
olga elena racea poggi parce que
penses-tu si avant nous avons entendu
des praticiens des ministres de la
défense commandant chaque maintenant
nous allons écouter le professeur dans
le domaine des relations internationales
maintenant je propose d'écouter avec
attention cette allocution
bonjour chers participants pour moi
c'est un grand honneur de participer
j'aimerais remercier vladimir poutine y
pour ses possibilités
je vais essayer de rester brève mais
quand même j'ai préparé une présentation
et j'espère que chacun pourra prendre
connaissance de ces planches pour
comprendre - vigion comment les
situations au pire ou y change dans
d'autres pays ici et j'aimerais
remercier les organisateurs et si je
présente mes remerciements mais quand je
dis si dense sur cet enjeu commence à
parler de ce qu'on appelle la
criminalité organisée et je suis bien
d'accord avec ceux qui ont intervenu
avant et maintenant j'aimerais dresser
un petit bilan comme mes collègues
viennent de dire le terrorisme aussi
bien qu'eux
la criminalité internationale elle les
problèmes des pratiques des stupéfiants
et des armes
tous ces phénomènes sont extrêmement
sérieux qui dont la lutte contre elle et
qu'elle doit être coordonnée parce qu'il
s'agit des menaces multilatérale qui ne
peuvent être résolus que ian crocker et
sur multilatérale et toutes ses agences
toutes ces structures doivent coopérer
entre elles afin de coordonner leurs
activités sur le plan local et
international et pour prendre des
mesures adéquates pour réglé d'une façon
pacifique et des problèmes entre autres
entrée parmi différents états et surtout
toutes les menaces contre la population
et ils doivent être prises en compte
qui en plus ne faut pas oublier des
menaces de nouveaux caractères ascii
surtout il faut protéger les push non
protégés de la population il faut
assurer une politique et bien ciblées
pour assurer la proposition de la
formation en contact étroit avec les
pouvoirs en comprenant les vrais acteurs
dans ce domaine et pour coordonner les
activités avec les pauses d'armé il nous
devons mettre en place la stratégie
parce que la réduction de la violence et
représente la responsabilité de tous les
acteurs c'est pour ça que tous les
phénomènes que nous voyons ici il faut
les prendre en considération il faut
lutter contre eux vous pouvez voir une
information détaillée sur mon site mais
maintenant juste quelques mots à propos
du trafic des stupéfiants
à propos du cas n à partir de l'amérique
du sud
si si on voyait des voix de ce trafic
il va l'aborder
l'amérique ensuite les destinées aux
états unis comme ma le collègue de panne
ou et déjà dit et il ya aussi le
problème de corruption en amérique du
sud le trafic de stupéfiants au mexique
surtout il faut pas oublier des
activités des cartels des syndicats
comme par exemple le syndicat du golfe
et les autruches surtout parmi les plus
connus qui sont la raison les régimes de
tous ces problèmes ici vous voyez les
états à appliquer comme la colombie les
rues parce que clichy a aussi déclenché
des syndicats et tous ces problèmes
parce qu'elle nous trouvons c'est ce que
nous avons déjà vu et entendu lors des
interventions précédentes et surtout en
amérique centrale
je peux de taille est que dans chaque
pays il existe certes un problème on
peut les détailler et surtout vous voyez
ici le triangle en question entre le
paraguay et le nord et les autres états
ici au royaume des résultats des
activités en 2020 financé par ms 13
et en parlant des bandes de jeunes qui
ont déjà mentionné qu'ils ont
pratiquement envahi le marché du trafic
des stupéfiants du parti au pire eu
n'avons pas encore vu ces bandes de
jeunes
sauf que peut-être ils sont déjà
présentes ici vous voyez tous les
organismes qui protègent les frontières
et vous voit ici vous voyez les
conséquences de ces activités que les
citoyens de mon pays subissent ce sont
les problèmes parce que nous essayons
d'assurer la
vous connaissez tous très bien nous
avons des zones spécifiques et qui est
gérée par les trafiquants de drogue et
pas du tout aux par l'état in depuis les
années 1990 nous avons aucun accès dans
cette région maintenant je pense d'une
autre région
je vais vous présenter quelque chose est
importante
les points de sortie d'hyper u ici le
rôle primordial joué par les forces
armées et j'aimerais commenté le rôle
des organisations internationales des
agences américaines aussi de l'agencé
américaine de la lutte contre le trafic
des drogues
c'est pour ça qu'il sait très bien et
cité sera nécessaire de respecter les
normes internationales
ici nous pouvons regarder en détail les
pays qui nous entourent combler quoi
d'or c'est un pays où ce problème et
existe aussi et elle des problèmes à
côté des frontières avec la colombie
parce que les prévoit un passage libre
eux parce que ici à des activités des ex
rebelles qui contrôlent ces régions et
si nous vous avez accès à toutes les
informations qui sont très précises
passé cuillères des citoyen du pérou et
de la colombie qui ont fait la
reconnaissance visant à assurer la
précision de ces données ici on peut
voir les voies passant par le brésil
[Musique]
et qui couvrent d'autres partie de
l'hémisphère qui sont appliquées dans
ses activités du prince et des
institutions évidemment que l'on connaît
les conséquences de la cobi 19
il ya aussi il impacter sur le marché
des drogues il faut pas oublier la
criminalité dans le domaine cyber qui
augmente et aux siens parce que nous
sommes tous ceux restés à la maison il y
avait beaucoup de phenom ii picchu où
les gens ont perdu de l'argent depuis
leur capture bancaire le puits les
cartes bleues et ici vous voyez mes
conclusions générales où j'essaie de
détailler le rôle de nos forces armées
dans mon pays est parmi les plus
importants qui sait la lutte contre le
terrorisme la nation la protection de la
souveraineté la matière de l'ordre
public interne pour assurer le
développement du pays parce que les
clauses armées participent aussi dans la
lutte contre les conséquences des
calamités naturelles tout ce que je dis
viens de mentionner
il s'agit des scénarios peut être qu'ils
sont un petit peu un but du passif des
mélanges des sujets aussi politiques et
des problèmes de la santé publique
écologique aux différents niveaux
donc nous devons tous utilisés ont signé
de ces changements politiques ce qui
dépend de nous et tous ces scénarios qui
peuvent et se manifester et sont pas
très précis maintenant je veux parler de
la coopération institutionnelle qui
prévaut le contre
le terrorisme le trafic de drogue les
criminalités organisées aussi bien que
les conséquences des calamités
naturelles et évidemment le trafic est
légal et du bois c'est aussi un grand
problème pour nous et au final la crème
a été international utilisent tous nos
points faibles
pour cette raison nous devons utiliser
nos forces armées pour décriminaliser la
situation en général partout où nous
devons battre contre tous les types de
trafic et il légaux y compris et de
trafic de stupéfiants des armes et c'est
ainsi que sur tous ces types de trafics
illégaux ils utilisent les points
faibles des systèmes politiques comme je
viens de dire y compris des ressources
financières afin d'intensifier leur
impact est sûre la politique ils étaient
dix dont le noyau le liant entre les
polices l'homme politique elle les
militaires et les civils aider certains
pays des deux amériques
parce qu'il ya un nouveau v12 maison
avec avec des concours aux armées au
pérou en amérique centrale
entre ceux qui financent le trafic d
armes et en plus ce sont liés avec
l'europe a assez que nous voyons
ainsi que par toi mr était restreint
aussi et vers l'orient de l'europe est
tous liés avec la criminalité organisée
et pourquoi est ce que la lutte contre
ce phénomène ne réussit pas toujours
parce qu'il manque une conjugaison des
efforts communs surtout il faut assurer
une bonne protection des frontières et
la défense il fasse car en parlant de la
criminalité transfrontalière un 'profit
profite du fait qu'ils cas des crises
politiques d'un certain pays
pour cette raison il peut se déplacer
par l'air par mer et par terre et la
sécurité nationale nécessite l'adoption
la mise en place des outils par toute la
communauté internationale pour bloquer
ces bois de trafic et légale des
stupéfiants des armes
merci beaucoup de votre attention pour
vous tous merci je vous remercie madame
professeurs pour ce commentaire bien
illustratif de votre analyse aigu de la
situation actuelle au niveau régional et
dans des dents certains pays de
l'amérique latine je remercie aussi pour
vos conclusions
chers collègues en tirant des
conclusions de notre travail comment je
dois dire ce qui est au cours de notre
session plénière nous avons su étudié
discuter certaines questions épineuses
présente à battre combattre les menaces
à sécuritaire dans la région de
l'amérique latine parce que tous les
intervenants ont mentionné
le renforcement le renforcement du rôle
des forces armées dans cette lutte
les forces armées vous à leurs missions
s'élargir
presque tous les intervenants ont été
unanimes à se baigner le rôle de
coopérations interactions régionales y
compris avec la coopération avec des
acteurs extérieurs à la région visant à
renforcer la sécurité en ce qui concerne
la fédération de russie notre
coopération est basée à être des
idéologique n'est pas fondée lé régime
est basé à une approche pragmatique que
je suis persuadé que notre conférence
est et cette session plénière en
particulier contribuera à renforcer la
sécurité internationales je remercie
tous les participants de la session
plénière
notre travail efficace et constructive
permettez moi de nous souhaiter à nous
tous le travail structure efficace hull
dans ces conditions actuelles et je vous
souhaite
il sentait de faire vu le contexte
pandémique actuelle mettant je propose
de passer une fosse de café je le
remercie et à la prochaine
au genou droit